[Music]
there is only one war that matters and
it is here
[Music]
hey everybody party in the dragon pit
its finale time so let's break this down
but obviously there are several other
storylines they have to wrap up there's
the stuff in Winterfell
there's the night king what he did with
Vissarion at the end of last week's
episode is then they had to sort of
tease what's going to be happening next
season they've implied that it won't be
as much of a cliffhanger but that
depends on what you define as a
cliffhanger it's always going to be some
WTF moment to end the season so
technically it's always a cliffhanger
but I think they're talking about no
cliffhangers is in wondering whether or
not a character like Jon Snow is going
to be alive but there's a whole bunch of
stuff happening in the next couple of
weeks and at the end of the video I'll
start to explain what the bonus video
schedule is going to be during the off
season as well as what's going to happen
when the books dropped next year if you
didn't see the video I posted about it a
couple days ago we might actually get
season 8 sooner than we thought before
so I'll try to explain all that after we
get to the footage so starting with the
King's Landing stuff you just see
Daenerys bring all of her guns and her
remaining two nuclear weapons to bear as
they meet in the dragon pit so they've
been very obvious about the direction
they're headed they want everybody to
come together Jon Snow even has that
line where he says there's only one war
that matters and it's here as in the
night king is literally on our doorstep
time to get our [ __ ] together but the
reason why they're rolling up in
formation here with her entire army we
even got the unsullied back from
Casterly Rock they must have sent a
raven between now and then you just have
to assume there's a couple weeks between
this moment on the boat at the end of
the episode in this moment here in the
dragon pit is a visual way for them to
convey to us what things will look like
if they go off the rails like look we
have all these people here we can turn
this into a bloodbath as well as convey
that to Cersei to look at everything we
have I still have two dragons even
though I'm assuming that she's
constructed one or two new scorpions by
now we might not see those but because
sir she's a master at throwing shade I
wouldn't be surprised if she taunts
Daenerys with one of her dead dragons or
the one that they were able to wound and
take down I'm assuming she'll see them
roll up with their forces and notice
that she's missing one of the Dragons
because she knows that Daenerys has
three so that's probably why Tyrion had
that line in the last episode where he
said don't let her go to you into doing
something reckless
if they attack you then we can burn them
to the ground so just look at Circe's
face here like she's very calculated
even though she's really excited to have
this baby and she has something to live
for now there's a chance that she'll
agree with Daenerys everyone around her
is hoping that she'll listen to reason
but she's really the wild card in this
situation because Daenerys has finally
come around on John Snow like he's
agreed to bend the knee Jaime's seeming
more sensible so if it seems like
everybody is going to see the light of
day oh my god there's a white we need to
come together then obviously something's
going to happen to throw it off the
rails you guys can let me know what you
think it is that Cersei does to
completely try to destroy this plan
because I think that's the direction
we're headed and that doesn't even get
into all the history in the lore of the
dragon pit there's so much going on in
this scene here even if you're not
thinking about the plot so we've had a
bunch of different looks of King's
Landing but we've never seen the part of
it where the dragon pit is like they
always film it from this side so like
Cersei in season six when she's watching
the great set blow up if she were to
turn her head a little bit to the right
she would actually see this so it's been
there this whole time it's just that we
haven't been to that part of King's
Landing before the really cool Easter
egg here though is that Cersei like she
blew up the great set to destroy her
enemies the same thing happened when the
dragon pit was constructed there used to
be a set there called the Sept of
remembrance but there was a faith
militant uprising maegor the cruel took
balerion the black dread and pulled a
Cersei blew it up and in its place built
the dragon pit there have been a lot of
parallels this season between Cersei the
Mad King and the more mad Targaryen
Kings maegor the cruel is just another
person that Cersei is emulating with the
things that she's doing in the thought
process that she's going through right
now so we're seeing the slow descent of
Cersei so this all seems like a season 8
thing because kind of like the night
king she's been atmospherically bad this
season like she's done a couple bad
things but aside from revenge on the
sand snakes they're just kind of
stringing it along like hey maybe she'll
turn a corner now that she thinks she's
pregnant again this baby might redeem
her a little bit the reason why I don't
think that's going to happen is is
because of all these parallels to make
or the cruel in the Mad King and the
idea that the writers of the show and
the producers would favor a human
and villain just as much as they would
favor someone like the night king like
Lena Headey is a fantastic actress so
even if you're not happy about the way
they've changed Circe's character that's
mostly in the name of her just being so
fantastic compared to a lot of the other
actors so that's one of the big problems
with the show is that you have like a
really minor character that isn't that
big in the book but they might have
amazing chemistry with other characters
so they find ways to include them that
they weren't of the books like sir Davos
got a big upgrade because Liam
Cunningham is fantastic last time I was
here I killed my father with a crossbow
last time I was hearing it killed my son
with wildfire so hopefully that answers
some questions about why they're
changing Circe's character so much but
once we get the episode and we see what
she actually does maybe she does
something to throw things off the rails
then we can talk about how she might be
the ultimate villain of season 8 instead
of the night king so 19 will always be a
really big villain but he's just the
personification of death death is coming
for everyone sir she's a more
traditional villain so speaking of
villain mr. eggs going up to the
Winterfell plot so we have Littlefinger
Sansa bran and Arya they're all
colliding even though bran seems like
more of a passive participant in this I
feel like a lot of this santa arya
dynamic would have been made better by
brands presences they would have just
briefly touched on him because he's like
the one thing that can tie this all
together and make Arya and Sansa
realized that what they're doing is
complete [ __ ] because chaos is a
ladder brand knows about all the creepy
[ __ ] that Littlefinger has done so all
we need now is for Sansa and Arya to be
in proximity to bran where he just
blurts something out because that's kind
of what he does now where he just blurts
out random information that might be a
big knowledge bomb it could be something
really critical but as important as he
is to the narrative the way they've been
using him this season is more
foreknowledge bomb like you touch his
little fingers dagger and just blurts
out chaos is a ladder whether or not he
fully understands the context of what
was happening when Littlefinger said
that so I'm expecting a scene with all
three of them we're brand blurts
something out and then they sort of talk
in through one of his visions as he
crystallizes his information on
Littlefinger and then they use that to
go against him like okay Littlefinger
needs to die
there's always the chance that he could
crawl into season eight it doesn't seem
like they have a problem this season
with not killing their main characters
but because this is the finale they have
to wrap up this Aria Santos storyline
and I feel like brand is the key to that
so as for the night king everybody's
talking about what's going on with him
is he going to break south of the wall I
feel like they're going to end on a
moment with the wall coming down but a
lot of you may have recognized that
they've changed a lot of rules about the
mythology of the White Walkers since
season one they're much more specific
about how you kill them
they've been very back and forth on what
the rules of the wall are is there an
enchantment like has it been broken by
brand did that ultimately lead to
nothing because he's still marked by the
night king he still has that mark on his
arm so now that he has undead vissarion
he might try to fly over it or bring
part of it down he has to get his army
through so even if he could fly over he
would still have to bring part of the
wall down but a lot of times when
there's a big mythology twist like that
like what are the rules how come he can
melt the wall now in the past they've
used the previously on at the beginning
of episodes like remember all these
scenes from previous episodes for big
plot points so I wouldn't be surprised
if there's some sort of brand plot point
from episode 5 or when he gets touched
by the night king that they include in
that just to let you know that he was
able to break the enchantment on the
weirwood and that also probably has
something to do with breaking the
enchantment on the wall which is
probably how they got this white that
they have in the box in the dragon pit
through the wall otherwise it might have
just crumbled to dust as they were
passing through the gate at Eastwatch
well let me know what do you guys most
excited for I know people have been back
and forth on things this season there's
been a couple great mythology twists but
a lot of time has been dedicated to
figuring out the way they weave the
narrative just because of confusing plot
points like how do people travel so fast
okay well clearly there's multiple days
happening within episodes even though
they're not very clear about that but
the really good news about season 8 is
they're going to start filming in
October which is just a little bit after
they started filming season seven last
year meaning that there is a good chance
that they can get episodes out by next
summer so we won't have to wait till
2019 anymore but what will happen is is
I'm posting bonus videos in the off
season I'll just do updates if we have
new information about what's going
what they're building what their
schedule is going to be so if you didn't
know I do weekly Game of Thrones even
when it's not in season and most of
those just wind up being things that you
guys are really curious about are things
you want to learn more about next year
we potentially have two new a Song of
Ice and Fire books being released winds
of winter in fire and blood so I'll do
videos for those too when they drop so
there are really specific videos that
you guys want me to do during the
offseason after the finale just let me
know in the comments but what I might do
is a video later this week on the new
three heads of the Dragon because the
prophecy has at a big twist recently
maybe something about Daenerys and why
she believes that she's barren in the
prophecy about how her womb my quicken
again there's a new round of that HBO
now giveaway happening all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video and what will
happen next is my QA video will post on
Tuesday so while you wait for that you
can click here for my episode 6 video
again and you can click here to learn
about Rhaegar Targaryen thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
you